kids don't want a bulletproof backpack
they want their own backpack they want
their JanSport their Patagonia their
North Face they want their own identity
we we did not want to change that we did
not want to force them into something
that they didn't want so as an
alternative we decided to take our
technology around plate and create a
thin profile plate that would fit
perfectly in the back of a backpack
until Parkland and Santa Fe this last
school year where I made the decision
that I had to put something in my kids
backpack so I took a law-enforcement
plate which is a level 3a just like the
pack protect material and just like the
pack protect capability and I put this
in their backpacks and one day at school
my son told his friends my dad put a
plate in my backpack he showed them and
the reaction was why don't we have
something like that